- Miley Cyrus has been sued
for copyright infringement
for posting a photo of
herself to Instagram.
This is exactly what happened
to Dua Lipa, Ariana Grande,
and Justin Bieber, who all
got sued for posting photos
of themselves because they
didn't own the copyright.
Just because you're the
subject of a photograph
doesn't mean that you own
the underlying copyright.
And that list of celebrities
is no coincidence
because the same photographer
took all of those photos
and sued all of those celebrities.
Robert Barbera has taken
photos of Justin Bieber,
Ariana Grande, Dua Lipa, and Miley Cyrus,
and they just couldn't resist
posting those great photographs
of themselves to Instagram.
And while it's counterintuitive
that you can be in a photograph,
but not on the copyright.
This lawsuit like all
of those other lawsuits
is probably going to be
a slam dunk for Barbera,
who's probably gonna
get a nice little payday
because these celebrities
don't understand copyright law.